une quinzaine d'escrimeurs de la
compagnie les lames sur seine nous
plonge dans l'univers d'alexandre dumas
plus d'une heure et demie d'un spectacle
qui a lié ce crible et théâtre on peut
pas faire de l'escrimé artistes et sont
à ras de terre
donc on a beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
toute la mise en scène et surtout le jeu
des émotions intentions sur scène pour
que les duels et l'air d'être totalement
réelle alors qu'ils sont faux puisque tu
une chorégraphie et que chaque
partenaire connaît bien évidemment ce
que fait l'autre sinon on serait mort
depuis longtemps c'est des vraies armes
très attractifs surtout pour les enfants
ça permet de relier l'histoire sans
problème leur a donné la formation des
plans on est venu par des amis on n'est
pas de la région
donc c'est sympa les lieux historiques
et le mettre en valeur par une mise en
scène est intéressante en fait
du coup ça attire du monde phrasé 550 à
un triple sa population le temps d'un
week end son château et son parc sont
ouverts au public et c'est le baron en
personne qui malgré son grand âge assure
la visite
il ya des gens qui ont régalé les gens
les plus calés que j'ai jamais vue en
histoire et en architecture
c'était des gens des états unis toute
une bande de gens d'amérique la chance
d'arriver
j'avais tout extraordinaire et c'est
d'ailleurs un visiteur qui a pris au
baron que l'accord de sculpter de cette
tour n'était pas celle des franciscains
mais l'emblème d'un ordre de chevalerie
féminine dont faisait partie la
châtelaine du 11e au 16e siècle un
patrimoine fierté de ce petit village du
perche